madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de cette édition du journal
il est temps de gagner la paix dans les
balkans à sarajevo 40 chefs d'état et de
gouvernement s'engagent sur un pacte de
stabilité slobodan milosevic et banide
cette réunion mais jacques chirac lance
un appel solennel au peuple serbe qui
fait partie de la famille européenne
alors que les chiffres du chômage sont
de nouveau en baisse au havre on vit la
fin des chantiers navals
les premières lettres de licenciement
arriveront lundi pour la ville c'est la
chute d'un pan de son histoire
nouveau drame aux états unis un
spéculateur boursier tue sa femme et ses
enfants et assassinent 12 personnes
avant de se suicider les vieux démons de
l'amérique se réveille et cette nouvelle
tuerie relance le débat sur les ventes
d'armes
le week-end le plus pourri de l'année
sur les routes de france 7 millions
d'automobilistes dans les deux sens pour
ceux qui s'appellent les vacances samedi
sera la journée la plus difficile la
pollution n'arrange rien
record d'affluence également pour la
sncf ainsi donc les départs en vacances
valérie maurice sur france2 bison futé
ailleurs voulons dit demain vous oublié
de prendre votre voiture ce sera encore
plus noir que noir
bref c'est tous les ans la même chose
tous les services de gendarmerie et les
centres d'information routière se sont
donné désormais les moyens et l'habitude
de fournir l'information la plus
complète possible aux occupants du
bitume
c'est traditionnellement dans la vallée
du rhône que se trouvent les principales
difficultés
patrick fandio mahdi diawara un passager
pas comme les autres va prendre place
dans ce vieux coucous dont on ignore par
quel miracle il vole encore
jean-claude lombardie scrute les routes
et les autoroutes mais ça a l'air de se
charger audi en défendant des revenus
dans sa radio il annonce les chiffres et
les couleurs rouges oranges 7 km de
bouchons un accident sur l'a7 tous
inscrits sur ce panneau géant tout
évolue minute par minute
nous sommes dans la salle de permanence
du crir pas de fébrilité pas
d'effervescence c'est pourtant le centre
nerveux de la circulation sur les axes
de rhône alpes et d'auvergne la
permanence téléphonique est saturé ils
ont bien de la chance
les rares usagers dont les appels de
détresse aboutissent jusqu'à lui ça
roule ils s'attendent à avoir des
problèmes mais ils valent ils veulent
éviter les gros bouchons les
embouteillages mentionnons les c'est de
redonner des créneaux horaires où ils
pourront circuler malgré tout avec des
participations mais avec un minimum de
datant quoi on gère le flux là aussi sur
le bitume dès ce matin
la tactique du gendarme c'est de
s'afficher être omniprésent presque
incontournable de quoi dégoûter les
petits malins qui ont quelque chose à se
reprocher la camionnette va être pesé il
ya surcharge
alors les 800 kg il va falloir les
décharges et parfois vous êtes afficher
l'heure vous avez des gens qui sont
derrière
alors que j'avais personnes la route des
vacances est encore longue
sur le chemin de l'insouciance des
mésaventures et éviter en respectant
toutes les règles de sécurité
la circulation dans la vallée du rhône a
été plus une circulation en accordéon
qu'un trafic bloqué par les bouchons
aujourd'hui c'est surtout environs de
vienne et de valence qu'on a enregistré
les plus fortes retenu encore à l'heure
qu'il est d'ailleurs près de 50
kilomètres dans le sens des retours
ailleurs les autres difficultés sont ce
soir notamment en région tout en voie de
résorption
la sncf annonce pour sa part 2 millions
de clients aborde 3200 train dont 2000
tgv au départ et à l'arrivée des seules
gares parisiennes
c'est un record historique l'actualité à
l'étranger à sarajevo s'est jouée ce
vendredi une version politique du devoir
d'ingérence après les bombardements sur
la serbie et le kosovo
les occidentaux travaillent désormais à
un pacte de stabilité pour favoriser
dans les balkans le développement
économique et la démocratie 40 chefs
d'état et de gouvernement étaient réunis
en bosnie pour gagner la paix arnaud
boutet jean cornu sarajevo conserve
encore les stigmates de la guerre ville
martyre devenu quelques heures durant
cité symbole de la paix reconstruire tel
est le mot d'ordre lancé par 60 chefs
d'état et responsables d'organisations
bill clinton gerhard schröder tony blair
jacques chirac
ils sont nombreux sur la photo même les
présidents des pays balkans tous ici
sauf slobodan milosevic
les participants du sommet appelle
officiellement aux changements
démocratiques en yougoslavie le peuple
serbe fait partie des peuples européens
il fait partie de la famille européenne
il a sa place parmi nous et je voudrais
le lui dire amicalement qu'il doit être
des nôtres que l'europe a pour vocation
de rassembler tous les peuples qui la
composent
pas de reconstruction sans paix durable
les belles paroles font parfois
l'économie des chiffres précis personne
ne sait vraiment combien coûteront les
travaux ce n'était pas l'objet du sommet
a attiré attention ça donne de l'argent
ça fait qu'on n'oublie pas à saper que
les gens sont tournés vers les
souffrances des autres c'est quand même
très important ça s'appelle en gros de
la politique et pas n'importe laquelle
une assez belle politiques celles qui
s'intéressent aux autres
la balle est dans le camp de belgrade
sommet une nouvelle fois de changer de
régime pour espérer obtenir une aide
financière et rejoindre ainsi à terme
autour de la table des négociations
ses ennemis d'hier ceux qui se décident
à sarajevo peut être comparée à un plan
marshall pour le sud est de l'europe
les occidentaux vont devoir faire un
effort financier massif pour créer les
conditions d'une paix durable dans la
région européenne la plus pauvre comme
les états unis l'avaient fait après la
deuxième guerre mondiale en europe les
décideurs réunis en bosnie ont fait
honte à faire face pardon à la diversité
des situations et également à la
faiblesse des structures administratives
et financières
malgré une aide de 20 milliards depuis
1996 la bosnie ne s'est par exemple
toujours pas relevé de la guerre jérôme
baugnies la réunion de sarajevo se tient
dans l'ancienne patinoire olympique 2 et
rats il y à 7 ans êtres à était sous les
obus aujourd'hui l'édifice et
reconstruit mais c'est plus que jamais
sur une poudrière que sont réunis les
pays du pacte de stabilité pour les
balkans leur tâche est immense
la première guerre mondiale par de
sarajevo avec l'assassinât par un serbe
de l'archiduc françois ferdinand
d'autriche au début des années 90 la
ville olympique redevient champ de
bataille
aujourd'hui encore elle est
particulièrement instable comme tous les
balkans les frappes de l'otan ont pris
fin le 10 juin
mais elles n'ont rien réglé au contraire
elles ont mis de l'huile sur le feu
chacun des pays de cette péninsule
balkanique qui participe au sommet de
sarajevo est en crise le monténégro s'y
rend en simple observateur et la serbie
de milosevic n'est pas invité elle est
toujours considéré comme l'ennemi dans
cette guerre non déclarée qui n'est
peut-être pas terminée en bosnie
la ligne de démarcation du secteur serbe
en orange n'est sans doute pas
définitive et au kosovo
les forces internationales occupe une
province pratiquement vidée de sa
population serbe
mais qui appartient toujours à la serbie
d'après la banque mondiale la facture de
la reconstruction des balkans s'élèvera
à 150 milliards de francs sur cinq ans
12 milliards sont déjà promis par les
donateurs à bruxelles pour le kosovo qui
est une priorité
quelques 700 mille réfugiés ils sont
déjà retournés
quant au pont détruit sur le danube
ils attendront l'après milosevic pour
bénéficier d'une aide internationale
à deux pas des maisons que l'on
reconstruit
d'autre part tout en fumée aujourd'hui
elles sont serbes
la vengeance est dans la tradition
albanaise ici la démocratie et la
stabilité ne sont encore que des rêves
difficile à réaliser
le leader albanais ibrahim rugova est
rentré vendredi matin à pristina avec sa
femme et ses trois enfants il a affirmé
à son arrivée de rome qu'il était de
retour au pays pour de bon
l'administrateur de l'onu au kosovo
bernard kouchner l'a appelé une nouvelle
fois participé au conseil de transition
l'instance politique qui se met en place
au kosovo sous l'égide de l'onu pour
associer les représentants des
différentes communautés
jusqu'ici monsieur kovac que l'on voit
ici pénétrait dans sa villa des hauteurs
de christina a estimé que la place qui
lui était accordée dans ce conseil
n'était pas suffisante
les enquêteurs du tribunal pénal
international ont annoncé avoir
découvert un nouveau charnier dans le
centre du kosovo
vingt-huit corps ont été déterrés a6k
tovo depuis jeudi les villageois des
environs étaient appelés à venir
identifier les victimes
par ailleurs la chine et les états unis
sont parvenus à un accord sur les
dédommagements pour le bombardement de
l'ambassade de pékin dans la capitale
yougoslave par l'otan en mai dernier 27
millions de francs une partie de cette
somme sera partagée annonce pékin
entre les familles des victimes ce
bombardement avait fait trois morts et
plusieurs blessés visite de jacques
chirac en algérie réouverture des
consulats de france à annaba et à oran
une visite du ministre français des
affaires étrangères à alger dynamise les
relations franco algériennes
rien n'est annoncé cependant pour les
vols d'air france la rencontre védrine
bouteflika symbolise pourtant une
volonté commune de dépasser les rapports
conflictuels
thierry thuillier maryse richard c'est
leur première rencontre
si sienne elle a duré plus de cinq 5
heures d'entretiens très cordiaux dans
son palais présidentiel
abdelaziz bouteflika dit sa satisfaction
et je crois que nous sommes arrivés à
une entente complète et totale que le
fait que tous ces quiproquos de voeux
devrait être calqué notre jour que
l'algérie comme la france
chaque pays avait besoin de gauche pour
la sécurité méditerranéenne puis il
s'adresse aux français la situation en
algérie se normalise je sais combien ils
sont attachés à mon pays je sais combien
les algériens les aime et je suis
absolument sûr qu'ils ne sont pas plus
exposées à quelques risques que ce soit
que n'importe quel algérien et moi le
club
au delà des gestes des décisions
importantes ont été prises aujourd'hui
les consulats affirmé depuis quatre ans
les centres culturels vont réouvrir
celui d'alger dès le 1er janvier
prochain le gouvernement français
souhaite aussi que la france reprenne
ses vols vers l'algérie au plus vite
l'élan est donné il doit être couronné
par les prochaines visites de jacques
chirac et de lionel jospin la vie chimie
angondjé rienne est de nouveau en oeuvre
tout cela va constituer au cours des
semaines et des mois qui viennent une
véritable refondation pour un bel aziz
bouteflika c'est un nouveau succès et
pas seulement du point de vue de sa
politique étrangère
lui qui est à fond d'un retour à la
normale la clé de sa politique sort
conforté d'une telle piste
car pour les algériens c'est la fin
programmée d'avions au sol devant les
rectorats donc une visite en algérie
d'ici la fin de l'année une date qui
n'est pour l'instant pas précisé
au maroc le nouveau roi prend ses
marques dans la soirée il prononcera son
premier discours du trône le monarque
devrait reconduire le premier ministre
socialiste nommé par hassan 2
abderrahmane youssoufi dans la journée
mohammed 6 ans en tant que commandeur
des croyants avaient assisté à la prière
du vendredi
philippe rochot
les portes du palais royal se sont à
nouveau ouvertes devant des milliers de
marocains curieux d'apercevoir le
nouveau souverain mohamed 6 dans son
carrosse deux roues j'adore ce voyage
qui le conduit de sa demeure à la
mosquée ahl fès bâti dans l'enceinte
même du palais est une étape obligée du
début de son règne et ils étaient tous
là serviteur courtisans garde royale
petit peuple des faubourgs mohamed6
règne sur le maroc depuis une semaine
mais il ne sera investi officiellement
que dans un mois à la fin du deuil comme
l'était son père hassan ii un descendant
du prophète mohamed 6 e place lui aussi
en commandeur des croyants et veut se
présenter au monde comme un roi pieux
c'est par l'islam que le maroc a été
unifiée c'est aussi avec l'islam que le
nouveau souverain chérifien entend
gouverner un islam traditionnel qui lui
servira de rempart contre l'extrémisme
mohamed 6 à regagner le palais royal sur
ce cheval noir qui était la monture
préférée de son père il explosera tout à
l'heure les grandes orientations de son
règne dans le discours du trône
on le dit sensible au sort des pauvres
et au respect des droits de l'homme
l'union des étudiants juifs de france à
manifester pacifiquement tout à l'heure
à orly sud au moment de l'enregistrement
des vols du des passagers pardon du vol
paris teheran 13 juifs ont été arrêtés
en iran en avril dernier sous
l'accusation d'espionnage au profit
d'israël
il risque la peine de mort téhéran n'a
pour l'instant divulgué aucune
information sur les activités qui leur
serait reproché les manifestants de
paris demandé plus généralement le
respect des droits de l'homme en iran
ce vol a été retardé d'une économie le
nombre de chômeurs a baissé en france de
dix-huit mille cent juin
cette baisse est favorable aux jeunes de
moins de 25 ans et aux chômeurs de
longue durée à trois exceptions près
cette décrue est continue depuis
septembre 97
c'est encore 11,3 pour cent de la
population active qui est touché
l'amélioration de la conjoncture
notamment dans l'industrie et le
développement des emplois jeunes peuvent
expliquer cette tendance au havre 120d
683 salariés du chantier où a été
construit le paquebot france vous
recevoir lundi leur lettre de
licenciement
les autres seront congédiés par groupe
deux sens pendant l'été c'est la fin
d'une histoire entre la ville et les
chantiers navals
le couperet est tombé en octobre 98
quand l'état avait décidé d'arrêter de
soutenir ce chantier au total avec la
sous traitance plus de 2500 personnes
sont concernées yann fronty dominique
bonnet
ce navire restera à jamais comme le
dernier construit par les chantiers
navals du havre le soldat shipment un
imposant chimiques chez dont le nom
risque de hanter pendant bien des nuits
la vie des ouvriers de la navale parmi
ses ouvriers
gérard et josé ils ont passé plus de
quinze ans chacun sur ses chantiers
aujourd'hui ils sont licenciés victimes
d'un plan social et que des problèmes
dont on nous promet et c'est que des
promesses mais on voit rien venir un
toute façon donc
un petit peu dépité dépité car ce bateau
était au départ porteur d'espoir le
premier d'une série de trois navires
commandés par un armateur norvégien
censé relancer une activité déjà
moribonde ses hommes y ont cru quatre
ans après l'échec est patent et la
facture est très lourde pour les
chantiers comme pour l'état près de deux
milliards d'êtres public dépensé pour
rien
qu'est-ce-qui grave
arrêt place au sein de la sphère ce
qu'on a fait est tout sauf les rails
comme des
or des chiens
pratique pour lui chez moi pour moi je
suis condamné au chômage
qu'est ce que vous voulez quelqu'un de
cinquante deux ans allez sur le marché
du travail
moi je vois pourquoi vous avec un taux
de chômage de plus de 17%
la ville du havre déjà sinistré méritait
un meilleur sort pour préparer l'avenir
le gouvernement a nommé un responsable
chargé de mettre en place les projets de
ré-industrialisation hui se veut
optimiste
il n'y a pas de raison d'être totalement
désespéré sur ce sujet parce que les
réalités potentiel d'emplois sur le
bassin du haf sont tout à fait
intéressante est positif d'ores et déjà
plus de 570 millions de francs devrait
par exemple être injectés par l'état
pour l'extension du port autonome
d'autres dossiers sont en cours mais
pour les salariés du havre
leur classement paraît lointain et tout
cela semble arriver bien trop tard le
multimédia est désormais une activité
qui tente largement les pm le chiffre
d'affaires annuel généré en france par
internet et de 7 milliards et demi de
francs 7 en extension constante d'un
million et demi de foyers sont connectés
et trois français sur 10 sont à
disposition chez eux un micro ordinateur
il y a là un gisement d'ailleurs
l'économie électronique occupe de plus
en plus de place pascal golomer
dominique bonnet certes le studio est
exigu le décor réduit au strict minimum
mais ce n'est qu'un début cette émission
ne sera pas diffusée à la télévision
mais sur internet accessible dans le
monde entier le centre images sur
internet
c'est ce que veut développer si pérusse
une jeune société française mais ceux-ci
clin d'oeil de l'histoire le studio
d'enregistrement ont été installés dans
le palais de la bourse à paris
devenu aujourd'hui un musée la bourse
qui découvre tout juste internet
longtemps très longtemps après wall
street à new york où quelques 40
entreprises du secteur déjà cotées font
un malheur la valeur de leurs actions
n'en finit pas de grimper chez super u
ils ne sont que 5 tous dans le même
bureau
mais il prévoit d'être 15 à la fin de
l'année dans de nouveaux locaux
satisfait d'avoir enfin convaincu les
clients après plus de trois ans
d'efforts
au début on a lancé senti très seul
parce que les gens les plus gentils nous
disait qu'on était à côté de la plaque
d'autres conseillers de faire des
boulots qu'il faut digne de ce nom et
c'est entendu ça pendant un an et demi
deux ans est-ce que donc au départ on a
été très seulement on avait une telle
conviction commencé dit que de toute
façon on avait raison et ben je crois
que maintenant on a la droite qu'on
avait raison
leurs clients 160 entreprises prêtes à
payer 25 mille francs par an en moyenne
pour livrer les informations les
concernant au public via internet
on voit ici les communiqués qui tourne
comme une agence d'infos au classique et
qui permet donc aux internautes dallest
après avoir une information plus
détaillée ci le titre d'un communiqué
l'intéresse c'est pour développer cette
activité à l'étranger que si perrus a
besoin d'argent 20 millions de francs à
trouver et cette fois ce sont des
investisseurs qu'il faut c'est lui une
tâche plus facile aujourd'hui qu'il ya
six mois
car de plus en plus d'investisseurs
français sont désormais convaincus qu
internet ça peut rapporter beaucoup
d'argent alors ils misent de plus en
plus gros plusieurs centaines de
millions de francs on est encore loin
des 5 milliards de france s'investit aux
états unis au premier trimestre mais
c'est un début bon il ya le côté à la
fois amusé
presque un peu gadget manière dont cette
façon c'est un investissement encore
modeste allons-y pourquoi pas il ya je
pense aussi au front pour certains
l'intuition qu'il ya vraiment quelque
chose de fondamental cet après midi là
il ne s'agissait que d'une présentation
la fère s'est conclue discrètement
quelques jours plus tard une société
d'investissement internationale
apportera seuls les 20 millions de
francs déjà jean louis michel et les
autres sont jetés à une prochaine
introduction en bourse laventure peut
continuer
l'ancien préfet de corse bernard bonnet
a été auditionné dans la journée au
palais de justice d'ajaccio bernard
bonnet a demandé une confrontation avec
deux conseillers de lionel jospin
michèle fines à la location la dernière
fois qu'il a quitté l'île de beauté
c'était en avion militaire bernard
bonnet revient trois mois plus tard mais
il n'est plus préfet de corse
un moment d'émotion car effectivement
j'ai j'ai quitté cette île dans des
conditions que je n'oublierai pas de
nuit et de précipitation mais c'est
aussi beaucoup d'émotion que de
retrouver les corses et la corse et
d'émotions agréable au palais de justice
les corses qui retrouve le presser eux
sont plutôt hostiles
bernard bonnet convoqué pour un
interrogatoire de routine sur son
curriculum vitae
pendant ce temps une poignée de
nationalistes à crochte aux grilles du
palais ces banderoles au nez des
policiers
l'interrogatoire de l'ancien préfet de
corse n'aura pas duré plus d'une heure
et demie parmi les sujets évoqués
sa dernière rencontre avec les
conseillers de matignon j'ai demandé que
monsieur le préfet bonnet soit le plus
rapidement possible
confronté à madame va le faire et a reçu
christnacht puisque monsieur le préfet
bonnet ne va pas tout à fait le même
souvenir que de la réunion du 27 avril
bernard bonnet refusera de s'exprimer
sur le fond du dossier
il répondra tout de même à quelques
questions mais uniquement sur son état
d'esprit est ce qui sera le plus touché
ces trois derniers mois le plus marqué
la spontanéité des soutiens je dirais de
franchement de toute la france et dans
tous les milieux et des mots souvent
très touchant sont les besoins de
l'instruction bernard bonnet pourrait
être amené à revenir souvent en corse
mais il préférerait être jugé sur le
continent et puis la façade de la
sous-préfecture de corte en haute-corse
a été mitraillé tôt ce matin 12 impacts
de balles de 9 mm ont été retrouvées sur
le bâtiment pas d'autres dégâts en
suisse une information judiciaire a été
ouverte contre les moniteurs après la
mort de 19 personnes dans les gorges de
saxetbach ceux ci pourraient être
responsables d'homicides par négligence
par ailleurs certains ascap et
australiens ont commencé de parler de
cette catastrophe
ses fans breitner les retrouvailles
n'ont duré que quelques heures
juste le temps pour les amis et la
famille de réconforter leurs proches
cela en plus de la chance ils ont
échappé au torrent qui emportait
vingt-et-une personnes encore sous le
choc ils ont vu la vague de deux mètres
des vallées le canyon pour la première
fois il raconte
c'est encore très flou j'ai des images
dans la tête mais ça a été tellement
vite
il y avait beaucoup beaucoup d'eau c'est
quelque chose qu'on ne peut pas
expliquer ça a été si vite tellement de
chance d'être ici parce qu'on a perdu
des amis formidables concert parle
beaucoup on essaie de se réconforter les
rescapés sont restés sur place sa
disposition de la justice
les familles elles ont pris le chemin du
retour vers l'australie à des milliers
de kilomètres d'autres familles en deuil
elle relise les derniers mots de leurs
proches ces derniers messages que j'ai
reçus de queyries avant son mariage elle
voulait partir et rêvé d' aventure dans
une rue de bendigo un magasin fermé sur
la devanture quelques mots l'homme parle
de sa fille encore disparu et demande
simplement que l'on prie pour sa famille
aux etats unis un homme de 44 ans
spéculateurs en bourse comme est une
tuerie avant de se donner la mort
le drame a eu lieu à atlanta en géorgie
est américain où il n'est pas nécessaire
de posséder un permis pour disposer
d'une arme
agnès garder
ces femmes et ces hommes tentent
d'échapper un tueur marc barthel car
entre un spéculateur sur vient d'abattre
froidement quatre personnes dans une
société de courtage en plein quartier
d'affaires d'atlanta
il est armé il est là haut sur le toit
de l'immeuble
il a pris une femme en otage les
journalistes commentent en direct toutes
les chaînes de télévision américaines
interrompre leur programme
car le drame ne s'arrête pas là quelques
minutes plus tard il entre dans cette
autre société de courtage
ils tirent au hasard cinq morts de plus
le meurtrier réussi à s'enfuir à son
domicile les policiers découvrent les
corps de sa femme et de ses deux enfants
8 et 12 ans ils ont été tués deux jours
auparavant sur les lieux toujours la
police retrouve une lettre dans laquelle
le tueur explique son geste
je n'ai pas d' excuses je suis sûr que
personne ne comprendra j'ai perdu tout
espoir jeu est séduit et ce système
écrit-il et s'adressant cette fois aux
polices il conclu vous devriez me tuer
si vous le pouvez après cinq heures de
chasse à l'homme marque barton décide de
mettre fin à ses jours
encerclés par la police à bord de son
véhicule ils se tirent une balle dans la
tête
petit boursiers il aurait perdu
plusieurs milliers de dollars la veille
du drame
c'est l'une des explications avancées
par la police qui depuis hier soir
cherche à comprendre ce qui a pu pousser
cet homme au carnage de l'art d'utiliser
la ferraille la nasa a décidé de
précipiter sur la lune un satellite en
fin de vie le but de cette
expérimentation est de prouver la
présence d'eau sur la lune
elle sera détectée au moment de la chute
par des télescopes spatiaux et
terrestres romuald venant daniel lévy
c'est une mission kamikaze qui va se
dérouler sur la ligne tout près du pôle
sud de lattre la collision à plus de
6000 km heure de l'unr prospector cette
petite sonde de la nasa d'à peine 200 kg
avec le sol lunaire
un choc qui va même causer un mini
séisme mais rien à voir avec une erreur
de trajectoire de la part de ces
scientifiques chargés de la mission
bien au contraire l'accident spatiale
ils ont méticuleusement orchestré afin
peut être de résoudre une énigme
scientifique à savoir la présence ou non
d'eau ou de glace sur la lune
avec cette somme nous avons en quelque
sorte une arme de choc
cette mission lunar prospector a débuté
il ya 18 mois
elle nous a donné beaucoup d' indices
sur la présence d'eau et notamment dans
les zones qui restent toujours à l'ombre
du côté des pôles des zones où la petite
sonde a identifié l'un des composants de
l'eau l'hydrogène marqué en rouge sur
cette cartographie beaucoup d'hydrogène
notamment au pôle sud
c'est donc là que le crash doit avoir
lieu et plus précisément à l'intérieur
de ce cratère mawson large de 60 km
la collision espèrent les scientifiques
devraient provoquer un nuage de vapeur
d'eau 60 kg de vapeur qui se
volatiliseront en moins d'une minute
peut-être qu'on va avoir une chance
d'observer ces quelques molécules en
train de quitter la lune au moment de
l'impact
à nouveau c'est très difficile et
quelques uns les autres scientifiques
impliqués se donne à peu près une
chanson pour l'occasion les plus gros
télescope du monde seront pointés sur la
zone de collision
malgré tout les chances d'observer et
d'étudier l'expérimentation sont infimes
un spectacle sans image que la nasa aura
malgré tout réussi à médiatiser et le
choc devrait se produire samedi en fin
de matinée heure de paris l'épave d'une
frégate malouines a été découverte à
proximité des remparts de saint malo à
la fin de 1995 il pourrait s'agir d'un
ancien bateau corsaire du début du
xviiie siècle
les fouilles viennent de commencer
reportage olivier sous olivier sioux
gabriel camille à 10 mètres de
profondeur à peine une épave endormi et
presque oublié depuis sans doute trois
siècles nous ne sommes qu'à quelques
encablures des remparts de saint malo
et pourtant ce mystérieux vaisseau
fantôme c'est par hasard que des
plongeurs amateurs l'ont découvert il y
a trois ans
depuis quelques semaines une équipe
d'archéologues oui ces vestiges
un travail de titan c'est effectivement
une zone immense un de près de 1000 m²
et probablement de près de mille mètres
cubes de couches archéologiques
puisqu'on trouve du matériel auprès d'un
maître et de fait nous avons dégagé un
peu moins de 30 à 40 mètres carrés et
sur ses trente à quarante mètres carrés
les quatre ou cinq cents objets que nous
avons trouvé vient de ckrl a donc de ces
20 à 30 40 mètres carrés et peut-être de
20 mètres cubes ou moins de 20 mètres
cubes de couches archéologiques
donc globalement on a fait un
cinquantième de cet immense gisement un
immense gisement et surtout un trésor
n'ont pas d'un banal coffre rempli de
pièces d'or mais bien plus les objets
humble et simple du quotidien découvert
dans ce qui reste du coup
de quoi en apprendre beaucoup sur la vie
quotidienne des marins de l'époque ça
rassemblement d'information à tous les
niveaux de ce que faisait le bateau là
où ils allaient là où il a été construit
comment les gens vivent d'abord comment
le bateau était équipé comment ils
étaient aménagés quels étaient les verts
de travail les airs de cuisine
l'outillage en fait la panoplie de tel
corps de métiers de l'artisanat bah
voilà pas retrouvé les ossements là les
objets remontés reste à les faire
parlant car on ne sait rien ou presque
de cette époque qui pourrait être celle
d'une frégate corsaire l'a fallu air
armée pour la pêche à la morue écoulée
en 1713
au sortir du chenal de saint malo une
hypothèse parmi d'autres que l'équipe
s'emploie à vérifier avec d'infinies
précautions ont pulvérisé l'ont tout
simplement parce que là il est exposé au
soleil avec le vent si ce décès shiva
humanis pareil
mais entre sierre et finalement la seule
chose vraiment certaine c'est que le
site de la matière et le plus riche
actuellement explorées en france cette
première campagne de fouilles s'achève
dans quelques jours à ce rythme soupire
les archéologues
il faudrait 50 ans pour venir à bout de
la mystérieuse frégate de saint malo
après l'or les français rafle du bronze
aux championnats d'europe de natation
istanbul en turquie roxana maracineanu
sacrée sur 200 m dos mardi s'est classé
3e de la finale du 100 mètres remporté
par l'allemande de voltaire et puis dans
le 1500 m nage libre sylvain crowe a
terminé troisième derrière un ukrainien
et un roumain en suisse en suisse c'est
la fête des vignerons la onzième du nom
depuis 1790 est il faut dire que cette
fête n'a lieu que tous les 22 ans c'est
à dire une fois par génération imaginé à
l'origine par les propriétaires de
vignobles pour qualifier le travail des
vignerons tâcherons cette fête fait
figure aujourd'hui d'institutions en
suisse à telle enseigne que 200 millions
de francs lui sont consacrés christophe
duchiron frédéric bazille il y à la mer
qui s'appelle mari et son fils ludovic
il ya les feuilles que l'on taille d'un
geste sûr il y a cinq hectares de vignes
qui surplombe le lac léman
chez les de la phrase de père en fille
de mère en fils de génération en
génération on est vigneron tâcherons ils
ne sont pas propriétaires de la victime
et marième la vigne comme si c'était la
sienne
musée du château nerfs vous aurez une
santé du tonnerre
c'est en quelque sorte la devise de la
famille aloïs le grand-père des petits
enfants des arrière petits enfants et
maris qui dirige aujourd'hui
l'exploitation
ils sont réunis autour d'un verre de vin
blanc à quelques jours d'un événement
exceptionnel la fête des vignerons un
genre de choses à l'impliquent du vin
qui a pour vocation de promouvoir la
bonne culture de la vigne et d'honorer
ses meilleurs artisans au travers d'un
concours 1977 1955 1927 et 1905 à chaque
fois un show à la suisse entre la
comédie musicale façon broadway et
concours agricoles ont pensé du soul
raison d'un groupe bouchard
c'était hier marie se rendent à la
cérémonie du couronnement qui ouvre
traditionnellement la fête des vignerons
on dirait pas il est 6h30 du matin les
4000 acteurs et figurants attendent le
début du spectacle marie attend aussi
inquiète comme catherine deneuve avant
la cérémonie des césars fort et voici
l'entrée solennelle de marie et les
garçons la seule femme parmi les 112
vignerons tâcherons du canton de vaud
doit ou non de la confrérie des
vignerons
je déclare ouvert la fête des vignerons
en 1999 dans quelques instants suite un
classement établi par des experts qui
ont inspecté la vigne de chacun les
meilleurs seront récompensés
copieusement applaudie par les 16000
spectateurs
marie obtient une médaille en argent
pour la qualité de son travail elle est
9e sur 112
je pense que la vienne ça suffit à votre
bonheur oui en 25 ans auront fini ça
tombe bien parce qu'elle possède l'art
de la vigne elle a mérité les honneurs
de la confrérie des vignerons
parce qu'elle est simple et naturelle et
qu'elles exercent un métier difficile
elle mérite le respect de tous plus tard
quand tu viendras l'âge de la retraite
elle voudrait s'en aller sur une île
déserte et marcher pieds nus sur le
sable chaud les vacances donc pour
certains c'était le dernier jour par
exemple à villeneuve loubet c'est près
de nice stéphane hamard frédéric besson
premier regard douloureux sur le dernier
jour des vacances
les moreau plie bagage direction la
maison dans la banlieue de
mantes-la-jolie loin d'être mélancolique
cécilia se réjouit à l'idée de retrouver
sa chambre c'était en décembre
c'est important
samus millwork pendant deux semaines la
famille tout entière à cohabiter dans ce
bungalow de 10 mètres carrés un vrai
toit sur la tête et les joies du camping
c'est pas très grand nombre est
suffisant
témoignage il reste encore quelques
précieuses heures avant le départ
quelques heures de bonheur pur où il
faut tenter d'oublier le temps qui passe
xi a le plus profité froid centre et la
sel derniers jours parce qu'après sur la
route un tract du passé non pas ça on
prend ça car on était là hier on chez
bny le prochain ben se fera sûrement
dans une piscine de quartier sur les
galets déjà on évoque le bilan des
vacances et la reprise du travail
17 heures cette fois ci c'est vraiment
la fin à force d'astuces tout est rentré
dans le coffre 900 km d'autoroutes en
perspective la moitié en pleine nuit
pour être tranquille au frais et puis
avoir moins de monde sur la route en
espérant que le monde n'a pas choisi la
même option que j'ai choisi prudemment
les moreau atteindront mantes-la-jolie
au petit matin
cécilia se réveillera dans son lit c'est
la fin de ce journal je vous en rappelle
les deux principaux titres il est temps
de gagner la paix dans les balkans à
sarajevo 40 celle d'état et de
gouvernement s'engagent sur un pacte de
stabilité
ce bonhomme milosevic est bannie de
cette réunion mais jacques chirac lance
un appel solennel au peuple serbe qui
fait partie affirme-t-il de la famille
européenne
le week-end le plus pourri de l'année
sur les routes de france 7 millions
d'automobilistes dans les deux sens
samedi sera la journée la plus difficile
ce soir dans le sens des retours entre
valence et viennent il y encore 50 km de
bouchons partout ailleurs en région les
difficultés se résorbe
dans un instant la météo patrice drevet
attention également à la pollution puis
bien sûr le point route tous les détails
avec valérie maurice sur la manière de
rentrer donc évité samedi je viens de
vous le dire 20h55 urgence par un mais
deux mais plusieurs numéros 01 10 le
dernier journal frédéric protat je vous
retrouve pour ma part demain à 13h
excellente soirée à tous
sur france 2